if I use the most satisfying sounds in
the world to make a song would it be the
most satisfying song in the world so I
took to Twitter and to YouTube and asked
you what your most satisfying sound is
well you can imagine as in any online
comment section there were tons of
really weird ones but then the ones I
ended up choosing were universally
magnificent I must say and if you
haven't watched the seen sounds before
I'm down miss and I have an obsession
with sounds I think because I have
really sensitive ears oh and something
super exciting close to the beginning of
the year announced that I'll be working
with epidemics sound all year round on
something Brad and that something rad is
that I'll be loading all of my knives
sounds the actual songs that I've made
like this one and the ones before on to
the epidemic sites for you to be able to
download for you to be able to make
tracks of your own out of the Psalms and
the pain that I've put myself through to
guard and record these sounds they
delivered to you now on epidemic but
more on that later so today I surround
myself with dozens of what you rated the
most satisfying songs in the world and
I'm going to take them and create a
soundtrack out of these what we call
diegetic sounds what my hope is that
this soundtrack will sound connectively
even more satisfactory than the singular
songs itself which sounds really
complicated and it's gonna be
complicated but let's hope it comes out
simplistic and obviously creating
something satisfying is very subjective
and that's personal as music is but if
we utilize the science behind music we
can use majors and minors and in life
you know you need a little bit of done
before you come up so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go major minor major
major something like this out of all of
your top rated sounds three of them were
pretty unattainable ones but I did
however make a plan what had the most
common satisfactory sounds that was
mentioned was the soothing voice of Sir
David Attenborough believe it or not
and now the truly popular sound is the
sound of thunder and we're gonna have to
reimagine this but but I found a way of
creating and then sounds really awesome
and real because obviously I can't bring
the weather inside my character check
this out I bring you thunder and was
this one you truly know I'm
overachieving a frickin harp okay not
like a golden one that you see in heaven
but I think this one is German oh yeah
oh yeah Marvis music
[Music]
it has been extraordinary of evocative
experience hearing sounds that I hadn't
heard oh what a perfect place for the
silent so around this time next month
I'm gonna give you a direct link to
where all my live songs would be up on
the epidemic site so you can click the
link in the description to sign up with
epidemic today less about that more
about you and I I'm enjoying this new
relationship we got going it's awesome
how you doing how's not darn going let's
be real shitty I know but don't worry
about that because you're awesome great
and I'll see you next week
[Music]
you